[Música]
qué tan de brawn jackson conocida como
baby jane y su historia este jueves al
convertirse en la primera fuerza
afroamericana en llegar al tribunal
supremo de eeuu en sus 233 años de
creación braun jackson superó la prueba
de senado con 53 votos a favor y 47 en
contra a través de su cuenta de twitter
el presidente joe biden aseguró que la
confirmación de la jueza jackson es un
momento histórico en eeuu dando otro
paso para hacer que la máxima corte
refleje la diversidad de ese país sin
embargo que jay no asumirá de inmediato
sino que lo hará a finales de junio
cuando se retire el juez stephen breyer
al que va a reemplazar para ello
entonces quiero saludar a nuestro primer
invitado del día el es rafael peñalver
abogado constitucionalista de eeuu
gracias rafael por estar con nosotros en
derecho américa de france 24
rafael le quiero preguntar entonces su
opinión tras la confirmación de que tal
y como jueza de la corte suprema un hito
un momento histórico de los 115 personas
que han que han servido como jueces de
la corte suprema de los estados unidos
solamente han habido dos afroamericanos
y ella sería la primera mujer
afroamericana en esa posición algo algo
verdaderamente histórico y más ayer
cuando fue confirmada por una vocación
de 753 contra 47 presidiendo el senado
estaba la vicepresidenta llamada harris
también una mujer de color así que es
una situación histórica como no
solamente por la parte racial sino por
la parte del rol tan importante que
están jugando las mujeres en el sistema
judicial norteamericano cuando yo fui a
la escuela de derecho solamente el 10%
de mis compañeros eran mujeres hoy en
día en la clase de la misma clase de la
universidad de miami el 60% de los
estudiantes del derecho son
qué bueno es rafael también recordemos
que esos 50 y 33 fueron unos
republicanos los que le dieron el voto a
favor de esta confirmación de que tal y
pues la imagen también que le hubiera
vuelta al mundo en esa confirmación la
cara de sonrisa no desde alegría de la
vicepresidenta cam a dejar irse cuando
ya hizo la confirmación de que está allí
el tribunal supremo pero entonces le
quiero preguntar rafael que va a traer
que tandil a esta máxima instancia de
eeuu especialmente dado su historial de
litigios como una abogada pública
mira el balance de la corte no va a
cambiar ella está sustituyendo al
reemplazando al juez stephen breyer que
es una persona de tendencia liberal y
ella su récord hasta ahora indica que
también es una persona de tendencia
liberal así que el balance de la corte
que está afirman firmemente afincado a
favor de los republicanos dónde hay
66 jueces que fueron nominados work por
republicanos y 3 por demócratas eso no
va a cambiar el balance ideológico por
el momento más adelante si los
demócratas pues logran presentar a más
jueces para que sirvan en la corte
suprema puede ser que cambie el balance
pero en este momento el balance
ideológico no cambia lo que sí cambia es
que esta persona una persona con unas
credenciales
extraordinarias y dicen todo el mundo
que ha trabajado con ella que es una
persona que es capaz de persuadir
argumentos sólidos
trato de traer un consenso a una corte
de directv